star top story this morning russia
showing signs of strength as its forces
pushed closer to the ukraine capital of
kiev but also some vulnerability as
russian president vladimir putin
approves plans for mercenaries from
syria and elsewhere to bolster his
offensive it's an indication of how much
russia has underestimated the strength
of the ukrainian resistance that backed
up with firepower from allies such as
the u.s and nato and that includes the
american-made anti-tank weapon known as
a javelin missile david martin reports
before the war started this was
unimaginable
outgunned and outmanned ukrainians
stopping a russian armored column in its
tracks u.s officials estimate the
ukrainians have destroyed several
hundred armored vehicles which are the
heart of russian military power the
russian army is equipped with literally
several thousand
fairly modern main battle tanks and it's
central to their way of war which is
focused on mass and on momentum retired
army colonel richard hooker now with the
atlantic council says one of the weapons
that has slowed the russian momentum is
the american-made javelin anti-tank
weapon which the u.s is shipping to
ukraine by the thousands once the
operator launches the weapon the missile
takes over and flies itself so the
operator can seek cover can it actually
destroy a tank absolutely it's a very
destructive and very effective weapon
fired from ground level the javelin
first pops up
and then dives down on the tank it will
come in on the target from a high angle
of attack and hit the roof of the tank
where the armor is very thin the u.s is
one of 15 countries shipping tens of
thousands of anti-tank weapons to
ukraine
you can see the ukrainian soldiers
carrying them into combat
not all of them are as sophisticated and
deadly as the javelin but in the right
hands a rocket-propelled grenade can
disable a tank you'll get what's called
a mobility kill which means the tank may
not be completely destroyed but but it
will not be able to move and it can be
it can be targeted with other weapons at
that point what's it like to
go up against a tank when you're on foot
it's very very terrifying for an
infantry soldier takes a lot of courage
and a lot of determination to fight
tanks like that the ukrainians are
supplying the courage
it's up to the u.s and its allies to
supply the weapons for cbs saturday
morning david martin the pentagon